Кримінальне провадження щодо порушення податкового законодавства
вже 2 місяці розслідує Фіскальна служба України
проти керівників Центру протидії корупції.
Голова організації  Віталій Шабунін впевнений,
влада намагається дискредитувати антикорупціонерів в очах суспільства.
Кому саме вони стали на заваді,
Шабунін точно не знає.
В кейсі Центру протидії корупції багато справ.
Забравши нас, політична еліта собі значно спростить
задачу знищення антикорупційних реформ.
Ось це ключова ціль.
Безвіз отримали, ЄС втратив свої ключові важелі впливу,
від траншу МВФ відмовилися влітку.
Це означає, що міжнародники втрачають свій ізначальний вплив.
Політичним тиском вважають ситуацію навколо Центру протидії корупції
правозахисники Transparency International.
В своєму зверненні вони назвали дії правоохоронців
елементом силового тиску і закликали владу не цькувати громадські організації.
При цьому і сама Transparency International скаржиться на тиск з боку влади.
Голова оборонного комітету парламенту Сергій Пашинський
звинуватив організацію  у зриві оборонного замовлення.
Правозахисники ж вимагали оприлюднити інформацію щодо того,
яка частина конфіскованих грошей екс-президента Віктора Януковича
піде на оборону держави.
Автомайдан теж неодноразово заявляв про тиск з боку влади.
дома у активістів проводилися обшуки військовою прокуратурою і СБУ.
ещодавно під час зйомки будинку одного з посадовців Генпрокуратури
дрон Автомайдану обстріляли.
Переслідування активістів носіть системний характер,
впевнений Віталій Шабунін.
Я бачу тенденцію, яка дуже схожа з тим, що робив Янукович,
бо зараз почнеться використання держорганів для тиску.
Регіональна влада дивиться на Київ,
і бачить що в Києві Петро Олексійович і кампанія незаконно, очевидно,
валить ЦПК.
Це означає, що і нам можна.
І вони починають фактично знищувати регіональні організації.
В Одесі в червні жорстоко побили громадську активістку Світлану Подпалу,
яка відстоює зелені зони міста.
В Запоріжжі майже вщент розгромили офіс антикорупціонерки Наталії Заболотної,
що веде розслідування проти місцевих можновладців
і постійно скаржиться на тиск істеження.
Правоохоронці, як правило, не знаходять в таких випадках винних.
Активісти і в Києві, і в регіонах прогнозують,
що ситуація може погіршитися вже восени,
коли політики почнуть підготовку до наступних виборів.